some kind of figure something out
recently Hennessey maker of ludicrously
fast cars announce their upcoming model
the venom f5 which is expected to have a
top speed of 290 miles per hour so
here's my question who's buying this car
I mean I get it there's always been an
arms race among automakers for fastest
top speed and yes the venom f5 will be
faster than its predecessor the venom gt
which only went 270 miles per hour but
hey that's faster than you Gatti's
Veyron Super Sport which is completely
pokey at 268 miles per hour
seriously who in the universe needs a
car that can go this fast I mean I'm not
even talking about speed limits these
cars are faster than the cars in NASCAR
and Formula One and those are driven by
professionals with crazy speed comes
even more craziness take that Bugatti
about which a ton of data has already
been collected at top speed the view
Gaudi has a fuel economy of count'em 2
miles per gallon let me put that in
terms that are a little bit more
practical if you decide to go all-out in
the view Gaudi with a full tank of gas
that tank will be empty in eight minutes
and it's not like you can reach these
speeds on i-95 to get to it's 270 miles
per hour Hennessey had to go borrow a
landing strip from NASA it was the only
place long enough
all of this is lunacy and what makes it
even crazier is that it's theoretical
lunacy do you really think anybody who
buys one of these cars is going to take
it to the limit
people who buy Buicks don't take them to
the limit this is bragging rights pure
and simple
this is mine is faster than yours it's
certainly not about money because these
people are as rich as rockefeller what
exactly do they have to prove